there has not been in the history of
humanity across any culture any book any
story any Fable there has never been
across the history of humanity any
respect put on the name of a promiscuous
female ever ever you name the biggest
conquerors that you can possibly name
from history Genghis Khan Alexander the
Great all of them they all had 100 wives
bunch of children Big G conquered the
world normal that is normal evolutionary
biology that's how men are designed to
be there's never been a single female
who's been celebrated for a promiscuity
ever in history it's always confront
upon and disgusting so yes we are
completely utterly different yes it's
different if a woman cheats on a man and
if a man is at a complete top level of
his life and ticks every single box and
if he decides to be loyal which some do
and I can be loyal and I have been loyal
but there's also times in my life where
I think [ __ ] it I don't want to be and
get a new girlfriend every single day of
the week I can do that and I can decide
to do that if a woman decides to do the
same purely because her value is high
enough to attract so many males because
she's beautiful for example it is
completely different and I'm gonna
explain to you why it's completely
different so buckle up